I found out like yesterday afternoon
that I had to do this talk so I Was
preparing so I did I didn't get a chance
to see the keynote I look forward to
watching the video of it uh hi my name
is Richard Campbell uh I am an old geek
I've been doing this stuff for a long
time I'm from British Columbia
this is a picture of my house on the
left and my neighbor's house on the
right we call this the animal Highway
I didn't realize until I put this camera
in that we get Bears every week
it's this is about six in the morning in
the summertime uh on a Wednesday because
Wednesday in my neighborhood is garbage
day
so he's just coming to see if I put up
my garbage early or not
and there are consequences if I do
so and actually we get fined if we put
out the garbage early it's quite against
the rules but it's uh that's what it's
like liver British Columbia it's just
Forest behind me it's like a big old
buffet for bears and they come through
and check out as you see he's actually
at the at the top of the driveway right
now surveying his domain and then we got
the garbage out before he moves on
I make a lot of podcasts I need.net
rocks listeners awesome Carl's not here
I won't be recording any.net rocks this
week I'm going to be doing some run ads
uh Carl started Darnell rocks back in
2002 which predates the word podcast by
a couple of years I came on board with
show 100 in 2005 we're at 18 we'll do 18
30 this week
it's already in the can and this
uh and then yeah a lot of stuff that I
do is based on.net rocks this talk
definitely is coming from all these
interviews we get to do we get to talk
to really smart people and so you get to
decide to synthesize the sort of vision
of what's going on I do an I.T show as
well
I'll run as radio and I think a episode
863 went up today and for a brief period
between 2011 and 2014 we made a show
called the tablet show
back when we didn't know what to do
about tablets and now we know tablet
development is just developing it's not
a big deal
all right so we're going to do a little
future prediction so let's refer to
Niels Bohr's prediction is very
difficult especially about the future
although I don't know what else you
would predict
so let's go through the obvious things
that are happening today that are going
to shape the way we build software for
the next few years I wrote the first
version of stock in 2019 thinking what
are the 2020 is going to be like and now
it's 2023 and it's not exactly what I
thought but did anybody plan it for a
pandemic in 2019 I don't think so
but obviously the cloud has come to
dominate in the past few years it was
true it was less true in in 2018 2019
but today if you don't have a cloud plan
you kind of don't have a plan your
employer is probably going to ask you
well how does the cloud fit into this
equation
and same for mobile devices mobile
devices are now the most common
Computing device in the world they are
the majority of compute the reason
iPhone and Android dominations because
there's so many of them we figure
there's four billion smartphones
operating in the world which pretty much
is one for every adult human
and we've transformed Society for that
fundamentally we are all cyborgs right
we have digital extensions to ourselves
now we tend to because of Science
Fiction think about cyborgs as the
digital stuff is inside you but a yuck
uh and B impairs upgrades
but if we don't think of our phone as an
extension of ourselves try losing it for
a day
like we're pretty agitated we don't have
that device around it's our
communication device we would just take
it for granted that we can talk to
anybody anywhere if they'll answer which
they won't
uh or at least message them in whatever
messaging constraint you currently have
the Venn diagram of messaging systems is
continued to be messy but that's because
it's so all-encompassing and so we can't
talk about
future of compute and and the kind of
work we're going to be doing if we don't
include these devices and how they're
going to evolve as well we know how to
make an awful lot of data
that's just a byproduct of having a lot
of devices feeding into common
reservoirs right the you know ultimately
a lot of what's made the modern machine
learning machine learning models exist
is because of this tremendous feat of
data that we're generating on the behalf
of others
and all of these are obvious Trends more
compute more Cloud more devices more
data nothing surprising here it's all
expected what are the unexpected things
where where are we going to hit limits
in the next 10 years
for me the big one is we are finally
going to run Moore's law to the ground
so Gordon Moore is a person he was one
of the founders of Intel they were one
of the first companies to make
microprocessors well actually they first
made Ram that was their original product
when when Intel started up Ram was still
largely core Ram little ferrous coils
wound with copper to store bits sounds
as reliable as you think it would be and
so the idea of building silicon
substrate Ram was a big deal and that
was an Intel's original product and it
was while they're making Ram that Gordon
Moore observed that for roughly the same
amount of costs every 18 to 24 months we
could double the number of circuits on
the piece of silicon
now they only were able to do that by
working very hard at it
later that would be called Moore's Law
it's not a law
right A law is something that happens
whether you work hard at it or not
like gravity you don't have to do much
gravity is going to apply
but for Moore's law to be a law
companies work extremely diligently to
increase the density of electronics and
it's worked if you I pulled this data
from Wikipedia this is a sort of chart
of the processor the density of
transistors in processors from the
original 4004 and 1970 up till around
now and you see how clean that line is
and that's because we have an
exponential number on the left of the
number of transistors if I didn't use an
exponent on the left and go up orders of
magnitude we get the hockey stick the
dumb graph where nothing is Meaningful
and then it shoots up at the end
it's a bad way to explain this honestly
I mean and we're technical people
getting our heads around an exponential
function is hard when I'm explaining it
simpler I talk about things like this
what is that warp drive for the
Enterprise no that's this
is a cray XMP super computer Circa 1985.
they've only they only made a couple
hundred of these that at in 1985 this
was the most powerful computer you could
buy they were millions of dollars uh
they ran on on uh 200 kilowatts of power
so you kind of need to bring your own
generator uh they're cooled with mineral
oil because they're running so hot
without mineral oil pumping through it
all the time it will melt uh you'll
notice it's kind of curved they're
trying their best to keep the wires as
short as possible so the speed of light
doesn't impair the performance of the
computer this is Leading Edge technology
in 1985 and it's knocking out about 1.9
gigaflops
per second so just about 2 billion
floating Point operations per second in
1985. they modeled nuclear explosions on
this the Voyager missions were computed
on computers like this doing the orbital
calculations
fast forward a few years say 2011. the
iPad 2 about 800 bucks uh don't put it
in any liquids that's a mistake
uh it Rhymes you know on its built-in
battery for about 20 hours and it's got
about
1.9 gigaflops of processing power so 26
years later the most powerful computer
in the world is now a device you give to
children
and they play Candy Crush on it
that's the advancement of society
and let's face it that's not fast that's
a 29 2011 device and a consumer device
at that today if you're a consumer you
want a high performance compute device
you buy a very expensive video card
right an RTX 49t these days if you can
find one there are a couple of grand
you know they're not cheap
but sixteen thousand cores in it
currently pulls down about 82 teraflops
at full bore
so
000 times faster than the iPad 2.
so 11 years later you know and that's
this also 450 Watts
so uh you know you can heat the room
with it if you like like I hope you
bought a big power supply because you're
gonna need it and if you want you can
run two I don't know why you would
nobody's mining Bitcoin anymore that's
done
and it's still a consumer device today
there's a today the fastest computer in
the world the super computers in the
world there's a race going on between
the Chinese the Americans and the
Japanese and the current leader like
literally this past fall was the
frontier supercomputer in Oak Ridge lab
so that's in Tennessee in the U.S that's
uh based on the HP architecture so this
is a massive multi-processor machine and
uh
1100 petaflops or 1.1 hexaflops
for about 600 million dollars
needs about 20 megawatts of power so
bring your own nuclear reactor
and takes up about
700 square meters so clear out the
basement
uh 13
000 times faster than the 40 90.
or 600 million times faster than the
iPad 2 or the cray XMP
Moore's Law
right that's what we're talking about is
our ability to continue to extend
compute and I like that comparison where
the Cray's compute power became a
consumer device like are we going to
have an extra flop device in our hands
it's possible I don't know what you'd do
with it but then we didn't know we
needed to play Candy Crush in the first
place right it just emerged that way
and Moore's Law is ending this graph
cannot continue why why are we running
into the limit well we're getting better
and better at packing transistors into a
smaller and smaller space and you'll
hear these terms like the 10 nanometer
process and the Seven nanometer process
and the five nanometer process and
scientists have built a one nanometer
transistor but only one of them
uh those are all rough measurements
they're not realistic the actual
circuits are more complicated that we
have good uh sensors now this is an
electron tunneling image of the IBM five
nanometer process so this is doped
silicon layered together
it's hard to measure what I'm at we talk
about Nano things all the time is
compute people the billionth of
something a billionth of a meter is
really really small people can't
understand a billion right same problem
is that exponential function and I
always describe this as if I want to
wait get you to wait for a million
seconds
a million seconds is about 11 days
but a billion seconds is 33 years
so the idea that a nanometer is to a
meter as a second is the 33 years
and we're making stuff at that scale
today that's how dense we're getting
this is kind of this is standing
scanning tunneling microscopy of a of a
silicon substrate the yellow dots
are silicon atoms the blue holes are
phosphorus atoms we talk about doping
silicon when we make integrated circuits
so they change their voltage Behavior so
you can apply voltage and pass it
through a semiconductor this is
literally the structure of it it is a a
crystal
and when you get down into those
nanometer scales we're running out of
atoms
and silicon atom is 111 picometers
across like 0.1 nanometers so when you
start talking about a transistor layered
together that's only a couple of dozen
anomalies across it's only hundreds not
even hundreds of atoms
It's Tricky right Quantum effects start
to apply like we're just getting as
dense as we physically can get and
that's going to be the limit and not
only that we can make these things at
all that that we can make billions of
transistors on a given die
for about a thousand dollars
right keep the prices stayed consistent
the manufacturing process has to keep
improving without really raising the
price so that we'll continue to buy them
and again we could debate like how fast
did you need to go and how density need
to be but we've built our entire
industry around the fact that we're
going to have more compute in about two
years
for the same amount of money
and that ends in the next decade
now there's a bunch of things that we're
doing
or haven't been doing because of Moore's
Law one is we have not really improved
architectures for the most part
especially if you're talking about Intel
they've more or less sold the same core
chip design
for 40 years because every time they try
to change it we got very angry because
it wasn't compatible with what we've
done before and we like compatibility
more and so at this point that
perpetually evolving x64 and x86
architecture has gotten fairly
convoluted the amount of steps involved
in a given work cycle even if it's going
at multiple gigahertz is complex now we
do have simpler architectures the arm
architecture came along quite a few
years ago and it was built for more
power efficiency more compute efficiency
it just didn't have the Legacy that the
other systems have but arm's pretty
mature today and it's one of the reasons
you're seeing more and more interest in
arm in general for compute because the
amount of energy necessary for a given
unit of work is lower in those
architectures
you can expect as we lose the ability to
get more compute for free by buying the
next generation processor that
optimizations and architecture become
much more important
now for us as programmers through the
large part we're insulated from that our
modern programming environment almost
completely abstracts us from the actual
underlying Hardware if you're living in
a DOT in.net land it's Microsoft's
responsibility to make sure that the
common language runtime compiles and
optimizes to the processor you have they
do that all of the time we don't even
think that it happens it's kind of magic
it just works
in that brief period where they thought
arm was a really good idea now they're
coming back to that idea again you could
compile.net to arm it went away it'll be
back because it's nothing that we have
to do it's their responsibility to do
implementations against the hardware
That's The Power of abstraction for us
I would argue that today the M1 and the
M2 made by Apple are the most advanced
processors out there architecturally
they're arm-based but they've also added
they've condensed a lot of things most
of the memory is here
they have tensor compute units or
basically units optimized to do neural
neural net calculations they have the
GPU integrated in putting all those
things in a single die putting 40
billion transistors together all working
and playing happily has some benefits
and so you know those are some of the
nicest computers we can buy today and it
sort of speaks to what the future looks
like and I'm I'm an advocate of William
Gibson the guy who coined the term
cyberspace while typing it on a
Wedgewood typewriter but his quote is
the future is here it's just not evenly
distributed
so if you want to understand the future
one of the easy ways to go is go look at
where the concentrations of real rare
Innovation are and what's happening in
Cupertino with processors like this is
pretty profound it speaks to what phones
should look like in the future and what
our other compute devices can be deeply
integrated circuits the modern
manufacturing Foundry
allows us to build very customized
circuits that are as close together as
possible to run as fast as possible with
the least amount of heat
and the least amount of battery waste
all right let's stop talking about the
underlying Hardware the net the real
constraint these days is the network 5G
was wonderful it was heavily advertised
a few years ago now it's here and nobody
can tell works perfect
uh I mean the
it's a good question uh in theory these
standards for wireless are about
increasing frequency to intensify more
data so more people can communicate
simultaneously the downside is as you
move up in Spectrum you decrease the
penetration
so our old 2G phones which we're living
down in the 900 megahertz range worked
beautifully in basements when we got up
to 3G and 4G phones and we moved up to
the two gigahertz band range we had
trouble communicating into in close
areas right some buildings work some not
so much it was easy to get into a
faraday cage rear foam wouldn't work 5G
bumps this up into the 20 gigahertz
range big increase in data density but
the penetration goes down a fair bit
it's blocked by things like
trees
bodies you know I've stood in front of a
5G Tower doing a speed test with my
phone and going wow that's smoking fast
and then I turned around
and 20 gigahertz currently doesn't go
through me
so there's challenges for these higher
frequencies there is the 6G
specification underway but there's no
Simple Solutions here network is going
to be our constraining Resource as
developers we have to think hard about
how we move data between points of
compute that's always going to be a
limitation there are no workarounds
largely for
uh for the Vlogs of physics the speed of
light that's a law
this the modern is a the the the
satellite networks that are going up now
are very interesting
uh for certain applications what we've
really reached is a point where much of
the parts of the globe that don't have
good cellular coverage can have
sufficient satellite coverage
so more and more we're reinforcing
Esther Dyson's belief that it was it was
easier to put networking everywhere than
it was to build a good disconnected
client
so if you just keep presume we're going
to have bandwidth everywhere I got I got
on the early starlink beta because I
have a place sort of up in the
wilderness in BC where the Bears are
even more common and it's an it's
impressive like that's just a pizza box
size antenna you need a clear shot of
the sky that's the hard part and if
you've got a clear shot of the sky
you've got about 400 megabits down and
100 up at 20 now at 20 milliseconds you
can game from there it's not as fast as
your your synchronous fiber but it's
faster than you would get in most
isolated areas
so that ubiquitous connectivity and huge
amounts of compute available in very
small devices you know the other side of
Moore's Law is the old Hardware gets
very cheap and so we were seeing in
things like automobiles where they won't
spend money on compute they still have
it
they're still they're now starting to
put 3G cell Services into all cars so
that all cars have Telemetry back to the
factory whether you want it or not
because it's more important for the
factory to know about how you're using
the car
so this model of the ubiquitous
Computing is emerging more and more
where every device has an IP address
and can connect to the network and is
communicating perhaps not for your
benefit but for the vendor's benefit but
it's always communicating and we have
options there we're going to be
responsible for a lot of it
I'd be remiss in just setting the stage
for all this to not talk a little bit
about the pandemic again when I wrote
the original version it wasn't the thing
but we've continued to deal with this
that's obviously in the later stages
our friend Sachi Nadella said was
famously quoted by May of 2020 saying
two years of cloud migration happened in
two months
as we as everyone discovered yes you can
work at home and we tore apart our
perimeter networks and shoved and
expanded our vpns and quickly shuffled
whatever we could into the cloud we
changed the landscape of work we changed
the landscape of compute I mean for most
of us in our industry working from home
was just not a big deal we've been doing
it anyway I do hope one day to make
either a video series or a talk just on
how video conferencing evolved over
those two years
remember that period where everybody
thought all of those inlaid graphics
with the hats and the horns and things
was a good idea it lasted like three
months for three months everybody had
fun with that they were like okay that's
really dumb and they turned that off but
that's that's the evolution of etiquette
and perception
and today it's really interesting to see
how everybody comes on with a face
initially says hi then when somebody
actually starts to talk most cameras go
off
to not distract like that we're
developing an etiquette for that model
we were rushed to do it
but we're also seeing the other side of
the pandemic we're starting to see the
economic impacts we the side effect of
mass layoffs was a loss of expertise
that in general all work chains are less
efficient today as we tried to gear them
back up and you have a 20 or 30 or 40
percent
inexperienced worker role in across
those chains of work you have a lot more
mistakes and they Cascade on top of each
other
we had the supply chain deeply disrupted
ports that were had had too many empty
containers and not and not enough full
ones not enough space to move things
around and literally going to take years
to straighten it out and then the
byproduct of all of that friction and
Supply was an increase in demand for
certain Goods which then got interpreted
as inflation and here we are it's 2023 I
hope you're having fun
now what does this mean for us in our
industry specifically because for the
most part
we've had 20 years as Developers
just in a growth mindset 2008 2009
notwithstanding the sort of Great
Recession because I think for the most
part technical industry was insulated
from that we were not as impacted as
much as many others
so I've talked to folks that have been
working since after the.com bus 2001
2002 and have just been build what you
want go faster build more you know
explore great ideas now I'm older than
that I started writing code in the 80s
when economics were a lot tougher and we
focused really hard on this contact of
return on investment
the problem is that when we're software
developers we rarely are directly
responsible making money for the company
typically the things that we make are
tools that allow those that make money
for the company to work more efficiently
if the things we're making don't do that
they're really not that important
you know this capitalist model has
always functioned on the idea of Rapid
relatively inefficient growth followed
by a period of sort of cleanup shaking
out the weak stuff a bit of a
recessionary period for a year or so we
cut the sort of fat off and then we'll
Grow Again
except that we've gotten good enough
with our economic models to avoid that
whole cleanup phase for 20 years
and now that we're looking at one in a
very serious way and folks are seeing
that you know what it's like to have a
five or six percent interest rate and
that you know new costs of things the
pressure on energy and so forth
companies are being more reflective
they're sort of looking back and going
are we doing the right things are we
focused on the important stuff and it's
in our best interests with our skills
and domain knows and the companies that
we're working in make sure you know how
your company makes money
make sure the things you're building
help that because we are productivity
amplifiers we're incredibly good at
building tools that allow the rest to
work faster to do more we can help
companies survive in difficult times we
work on the right things
all right
we wanted to talk about technology we've
kind of set the stage here is the
landscape we live in today
so now that we know we're living in a
cloud and we're living in a cloud world
mostly smartphones we're not going to
count on you compute going much faster
and in general our employers and our
customers are going to be tighter with
their cash
what should we do
start with the browser Market because
the browser Market is kind of stable now
if you really want to use up a lot of
memory on your computer there's Chrome
if you want to be frustrated with how
well your websites working Safari if you
want to use a browser nobody else cares
about there's Edge
and if you want to be an angry Anarchist
there's Firefox like you have choices
right
there's no perfect solution to any of
these they're nobody's utterly
dominating the market I mean Chrome is
still a big player especially for your
typical employer
that's likely the browser you're using
you tend to build to that and we're
clearly seeing the rough edges we're not
all the same things work together but we
have the tooling sets and
you know on.net rocks we made fun of the
rapid rates like hey we've got an
hour-long show here there'll be at least
two more Frameworks before this is done
I feel like that pace is eased off a
little I think people want a certain
level of stability you know angular is
not the new sexy anymore but it's it's
utilization level inside of larger
companies is massive and those top three
across the board seem to be that you
know majority of web development and
we're still doing mostly browser
development especially for companies
because it's also a deployment issue and
they're always running the latest
version and that's things we want from
that even if we have to constrain the
feature system what and getting and all
of these libraries have some degree
advantages for working in the in the
heterogeneous client world that we have
that people are expected to be able to
use those pages on a phone and on a
tablet not a PC and have a reasonable
experience on all of them it's still not
easy
development for us has all the easiest
time of development was when the device
you were writing the code on was the
device it would normally run on that
just hasn't been true for 20 years
whether we acknowledge it or not now we
typically are writing on a desktop PC or
a robust laptop but we're running it on
smaller form factor devices and that's a
way more difficult thing to develop for
it's a more complicated model it's a
longer cycle but if you're not
respecting that cycle you struggle with
what you're making
the progressive web app movement has
helped us at the minimum to give us an
icon for regular users to be able to get
to that web page because goodness knows
they couldn't figure bookmarks out
right so now we have an icon it starts
up a frameless browser where that's good
enough there's a bunch of other great
stuff in pwa and the three guys who use
it think it's great
and then there's our friend Steve
Sanderson who brought us web assembly in
the form of what would eventually be
known as Blazer now he didn't invent it
you know he wasn't first but he
definitely brought it for us in the net
Community back in 2016 at the NDC
conference in Oslo he showed it off for
the first time with a very Bizarro
version of c-sharp that allowed us to
run C sharp on the browser and really
what webassembly has evolved into is a
kind of container strategy where the
inside surface of the container is this
browser environment a Sandbox that's
relatively safe to operate within and
you can introduce almost any kind of
code Microsoft took their time
committing to Blazer Microsoft doesn't
like being first it seems these days
they kind of sat on that project as an
experimental project until go Lang for
web wa shipped as soon as that happened
well then Blazer came out but it was
like nobody wants to attack JavaScript
but we do want a program in the
languages we want to program the devices
we want to program in and wa gives us
this ability to program in the languages
of choice down on the client device
still in the browser so I still have my
deployment issue solved I still have
continuous update models where every
time you click on it you get the latest
version like all of the benefits of
working in web development but now I get
the language that I want to use
if you've listened to the show you know
we've been talking about other places
that this container could run I mean
Blazer made it absolutely obvious to us
that we can run it on the server again
run it on the client
but now it's interesting to start
thinking about different points of
compute
I don't want this code to necessarily
run on the client device but I want it
to run close to the client so could I
Define
a set of parameters for where this x
block of code could execute that it
could run in a CDN an edge point of some
kind
you know and this is all experimental
but I'm hearing it more and more often
that the web assembly is a another kind
of container
and what the potential of that offers to
us long term so if you haven't explored
this world and started poking around
what's possible there just understand
this is an area of growth extremely
smart people are looking at where they
can take webassembly to
now if you want Dumber areas we could
talk about web 3.
it's easy to make fun of Mostly because
it's pretty silly uh I see it coming
down to three Central ideas
decentralized web is I think the most
reasonable aspect of web3
we
if you think about web one late 90s
early Arts thehold.com
boom.com from Microsoft perspective for
the idea of the internet becoming a
popular thing
that was very decentralized people ran
web servers on machines under their
desks connected to the internet it
wasn't a good idea but it's something we
did
and it was powerful and flexible except
it just wasn't reliable right sometimes
that machine sometimes you trip over the
power cord sometimes the cat barfs into
the CD drive right like stuff happens
and that machine was actually on the
internet
web 2 was far more centralized right we
gave up our ownership of those devices
in on the internet for a service
provider it's just that we chose folks
like Facebook
but you can still put geocities in that
can as well if you want but we now were
getting into more interesting compute
models with distributed execution
and the problem of course is that those
products turned into other kinds of
exploitation of us
and us not controlling the value we're
actually making and now everyone's a
little bit sick of it and so
decentralized web is becoming hip again
just trying to do it in a better way
meaning running on the cloud you could
still be largely decentralized because
it's all about ownership of data so can
you run your own Services through a
provider who's not really running
competing Services directly but rather
having other people compete in that
space I look more to stuff like the
Shopify model
where there's no reason for you to
employ your own e-commerce engine
anymore when you can go to a Shopify and
run their engine for a set fee with many
thousands of other people running their
own the same engine for their products
the one person not running an e-commerce
engine is Shopify themselves right
they're not a competitor in your own
space that's fairly decentralized I can
live with that the silly Parts when we
get into web 3
I mean blockchain's not inherently
stupid it's just wildly misapplied right
the idea of a distributed data engine is
pretty compelling
it's just that people don't think about
it well
you know when I have a customer asking
me about well we got to use blockchain
it's like why because you saw it in a
magazine
like what do you want from it what
what's the difference and often with
most companies they still want to be
central point of control it's like so
you don't want blockchain the idea that
other entities can introduce
transactions on into this data
independent of you
is the basic stepping Point like if
you're not going to do that then what
are you talking about
why do you need this but blockchain's
got the problem that BitTorrent has
bittorian's problem was that it came out
of Napster a lot of stealing music it
was a good protocol used for where its
initial use was a nefarious use that was
ultimately illegal and blockchain has
the same problem it's bound to crypto
and as we're seeing pretty clearly these
days
yeah crypto is pretty much a Ponzi
scheme and so are we going to get
something from it eventually maybe are
most people just going to lose their
money Sears seems like it it's easier to
see that now than it than we saw it
before but that's the part that's really
contaminating web 3 is these fairly good
ideas bound up with an idea that was
very easy to exploit to fairly
destructive purposes and so I think most
of us these days who are a little more
serious about stuff are going you know I
think I'm just going to stay back from
that
rodeo and let it wind down and then
we'll see what pieces are left in the
end
uh web 2 didn't happen overnight either
this exploration of new ways to use the
internet it is an exploration it takes
time there's no other way to do it and
so it's a question of are you gonna jump
in and be part of that exploration or
are you going to witness it and then
make your move later on
if you think like an engineer you're
pretty conservative and you're not the
first you're big on the the it manager
of change is good you go first
not a bad way to look at crypto these
days
.net's in a good place
goodness knows I'm glad about that I
make a podcast called.net rocks and back
in 2011 we thought maybe that doesn't
Rock and things were pretty hard about
11 years on 12 years on gotten is
rocking pretty hard
they've done a remarkable thing they've
Rewritten the entire thing to be a
cloud-centric heterogeneous client
platform with some limitations without
having to replace all the Tooling in the
process
I mean if you learned how to develop
against.net in 2010 with Studio 2010 I
can drop you on to Studio 2022 and.net
core and you won't be confused you'll
more or less get it there's a bunch of
new stuff and there's some edges to
things and we focus on some other
elements but really we've had a complete
overhaul of this 20 year old stack over
the past six seven years and yet we
don't have to relearn we don't have to
start over we get to move most of our
code on onto it and the new things you
write we use familiar skills if anything
the biggest problem Microsoft has right
now with this is that it's so con it's
so similar we still have our old
practices we're not using new language
features we're not taking advantage of
the new stuff that's been brought to it
and the only way they're going to fix
that is tooling
because compatibility is so important
they're not going to take stuff away if
you're using c-sharp two constructs
they're going to keep working
but you probably want to use a new one
so I think you're going to start having
more clippy events where it popsically
goes wow your coding like it's 2007. can
I help you because you can help
and the big new tool in this space is
Maui so this is the culmination of a
tremendous effort inside of Microsoft to
consolidate a client development
Solution that's this deals with the
heterogeneous client and multiple
platforms it's still pretty Raw
again the conservative engineering type
of look at that and go you know I'll let
you guys iterate on that a couple of
times you guys you kind of get it right
at the third version you're kind of like
in a version and a half right now so
I'll give you a little more time but the
goal is challenging the idea of this
magical unified client development model
that works for all the devices something
we want our customers couldn't care less
about the customer only cares that it
runs on their device they don't care if
it runs on anybody else's device
we're the ones who want to write one
code base that runs on all of those
devices because otherwise we can't keep
them in sync or we're leaving somebody
out and they're angry with us and that's
never fun so this is Microsoft's
client-side attempt on this and I mean
I'm I'm excited for them the set the
seven version is substantially better I
think this will be almost sexy by
November of this year with DOT net eight
it just takes time for them to get this
many features and this many teams
cooperating across the stacks and if
you're sticking with web development I
don't blame you because it does it
solves this problem with its own set of
limitations I've yet to see a Maui
implementation of a cross platform
client solution where I said wow you
couldn't do that with web
we're not there yet
we might be I don't know the answer to
that
we've talked about this a few times on
the show and it doesn't seem to be going
away the Power Platform
so here's the other reality is that we
kind of know what the client's landscape
looks like we know there's phones and
tablets and PCs
an awful lot of our data over forms
problem space in in work is all
dependent on the cloud tenant that our
employer has anyway and so the fact that
we can essentially run this set of tools
that builds a ball a bulk of that for us
is pretty compelling
but even more importantly
these tools are Sim are straightforward
enough that a domain expert can take a
pretty good shot at an 80 solution
for our workflow for a company
and then it needs to be cleaned up by
some of a bit more experience
but a lot of ux development can be done
by the person who's going to use it
now this has happened before this is
access and Visual Basic in the middle
90s where most people who grab those
tools were domain experts not Developers
they became developers later and I think
we're seeing another wave of this
but the parts that we find the least
pleasant as professional developers that
UI multi-platform UI problem this thing
kind of knocks out
and then it has a set of hooks back to
backend services with some limitations
they're all customizable we as
professional developers can build
additional endpoints for the Power
Platform and if you're good at the ux
side you can build custom components on
the ux side for these domain experts to
use too but I'm looking at our to-do
list and we're not getting to the bottom
of it so if there's a group of people
out there that want to move things along
by taking on some of that work
do it
the way Microsoft's license the thing
it's for internal apps only
you pretty much cannot put a power app
into public it has to be authenticated
members of the tenant
so it's for internal apps
they weren't fun to build in the first
place
so anything we can do to get more of
those off the table and modernize them
right you're looking at that web forms
app that the CIO wants to run on their
iPad
and suddenly the fact that a Power
Platform could get you a prototype of
that in pretty short order it's pretty
compelling
I've mentioned wa in the context of
containerization containerization is an
ongoing evolving thing it's only getting
bigger I got a recent show up where
we're talking about Azure application
identities
and that ties into giving a security
context to an application it's going to
run in the cloud in a lot of ways
containers do that too right we're
demanding a manifest saying this is what
the app this is the resources the app
needs this is the operating contents it
needs to operate in here are the rights
that it needs the access points that it
needs and more importantly if it tries
to do anything it isn't in that kill it
containers are just the evolution of
that
um in the next few years I think we're
going to see containerization of
software in General on desktop machines
because of the security problems
that when a given piece of software gets
exploited and it tries to do anything
outside of its normal set of behaviors
the operating system recognizes that
it's exceeding its container limits and
stops it
now that was always a good idea and
Microsoft's tried to implement this in a
few different ways for a long time but I
think the security context is going to
win
I look at what's happened in cyber
Insurance in the past couple of years
today if you want to get Cyber Insurance
not only is it more expensive but even
multi they and they require multi-factor
authentication but more and more I'm
seeing things like you're required to do
a privileged access audit
I wouldn't surprise me at all if the
insurers at some point say if the apps
if your apps aren't running containers
you're not insured
because they see them as ways to avoid
the exploits that the black hats are
using
so that might be what pushes this
technology over the top is it becomes a
consistent industry-wide way to resist
the ransomware and other security
attacks
and if you're feeling a little
overwhelmed with all the stuff I'm
rattling through because I get to just
tell stories for a living I don't have
to implement any of it which is why it's
all easy for me
um
that's okay
there are a bunch of ways to have a
great Development Career
staying on the Leading Edge is really
fun if it's fun for you you know the
upside the downside to the Leading Edge
is also the bleeding edge and sometimes
you bleed
you can also have a great career and
many people do by becoming an expert in
a stack that your company values and
staying that expert it may not be the
newest technology anymore but it's the
one the company relies on and they need
those experts and they need you to
continue to grow and to be good at that
technology and to keep it functional for
the organization to keep doing the
things it needs to don't jump because
the thing is new you jump because it can
no longer solve the business problems
that it needs to solve
I've talked to folks that started doing
web forms development in 2005 and their
company still uses a ton of it they're
and it works it's reliable it's known
set of problem spaces they have a you
know they're 15 years into this or plus
and do I really need to to jump to a new
staff it's like no those apps aren't
going away
and in fact even when they are they're
going to technologies that are
orthogonal to web forms anyway that's
why Blazer got so hip if you're a web
forms developer and you look at Blazer
you're just not that surprised this
looks like something you've done it's
not that hard to jump onto than you
stack
so the question is what did you want to
do do you want to be part of the group
of folks that are always learning and
pushing on a new thing or you're going
to be the expert in a given set you find
a space that you like and you stay in
that space and you get really good at
that space and now you're an expert in a
diminishing pool
like your pay's still going to be good
but you need to maintain your expertise
you need to keep figuring out where the
limits are and what's possible like it
doesn't mean you ever stop learning we
don't get to do that in this industry
but it's a question of what you focus on
do you really want to learn the new bits
where we're all just trying to figure it
out or you continue to expand on the
space that you're in there's not one way
to do a great career
let's talk about artificial intelligence
and I use this image for the simple
reason that it's it is the reason that
we think about AI the way we think about
it it's terrible term
was coined in the 1950s by a guy named
Marvin Minsky when he's trying to sell
stuff to the US Military
the first time regular humans heard the
phrase artificial intelligence it was in
the movie 2001 A Space Odyssey and how
and then he tried to kill everybody
and set up our relationship with
artificial intelligence going forward
it's an umbrella term the one thing I
know for sure about artificial
intelligence is as long as somebody's
calling something artificial
intelligence it's because it doesn't
work
as soon as it does work it gets a new
name
right it becomes deep learning or
Predictive Analytics or you know speech
text systems as long as it doesn't work
it's AI
and so when folks talk to me about hey
you know I'm working on this AI problem
it's like what are you really working on
like are you is it a machine learning
model that's the new thing right like
really what really came out of Jeff
hinton's papers in 2011 that led to
stuff like Siri and all the voice
recognition and ultimately's vision
interpretation models is all deep
learning models based on machine
learning right and this particular
graphic I like because the short lines
are the oldest Technologies those
planning schedule and optimization those
are back in the 50s expert systems and
Robotics from the 1970s original speech
recognition systems go back to the 80s
and then in the 2010s we get this
current crop of image recognition Vision
systems language interpretation
and we can incorporate it into our
software today there are good libraries
you don't have to invent stuff it isn't
research anymore you want an image
recognition module it's a module you
load it into your software you have an
image to be recognized and it can
recognize it
this is a real thing the software was
doing what you told it to do
said oh no no three dogs
and you've run into the chat Bots right
they're out there you it their first
line tech support for almost everything
today you're going to get a chat bot for
us and sometimes they're speech Bots
and they are getting better doesn't mean
they're good we all learn to say agent
very early on if we want to get out of
that Loop
these are again tooling sets that we can
work with the area that I I'm really
fascinated by right now that Microsoft's
working on are these form recognizers
so the idea that I can I can use an
image recognition system to look at a
form and it recognizes what is form and
what is data and then Associates the two
together into value pairs
that's pretty cool right that we have a
different strategy to digitizing a form
rather than building it by hand in in
code that now the tool would actually
recognize it for your generator for you
I I this was really about using
initially paper because they called it a
form recognizer like can I parse a page
and have it pull the data out of it but
I immediately thought hey aim that at a
web forms page and re reimburse it for
me
and make it into Power Platform stuff
like can you could I just have a tool
thumb through all of the different views
in an application and regenerate it in a
new language
why not we have machine learning models
that are capable of parsing the data
the final area in the machine learning
spaces that has gotten powerful actually
has been power for a while and when
people are asking about hey my kids
getting into technology like where's the
big career opportunity it's analyzing
data we have more data before we're
analyzing it less and less effectively
because we're just outnumbered there's
so much data and only so much time the
good news is the cloud is making things
simpler for us in the 90s we had most of
these predictive analytic models it's
just that each one of them represented a
huge amount of compute and so you'd do a
bunch of pre-work to figure out what the
most likely analytic model will be
effective on this given data and then
you'd build out a system and run it once
and it would take weeks
today this is a couple of hours in Azure
load the date you'll spend more time
loading the data up then you'll run all
of the predicted analytic models and
then you'll run model analysis against
the models to figure out the one that
fits the data set best
for twenty dollars worth of compute
so we have better tools than ever for
doing Advanced analytics and as we go
and when we talk about Advanced
analytics you know the predictive model
is really what's the next number that's
going to come from this what's the trend
on these is this going up as it's going
down right we have plenty of tools in
those sorts of forms as we start adding
in machine learning we do it in bulk
we're able to do more of them faster and
compare them so that we can select
models more efficiently it's less time
or your space and more just hammering it
with compute but you can go to a more
advanced stage
given you take a predictive model and it
says this is the most likely outcome now
you can actually run a scenario beyond
that you're getting into prescriptive
analytics so you're cycling the
predictive model with actions
you've been experienced this is where
you know it or not have you lately
thrown a bunch of stuff in a shopping
cart and abandoned it and then you get
an email from someone saying hey you put
this stuff in your cart
like can I give you a 10 off so you'll
go buy it
you're seeing a prescriptive model
saying how often do I tickle this person
now that they've shown some interest to
increase the likelihood of completing a
sale there's no humans involved it's all
software
but they're now running these
prescriptive explorers to say how often
should I hit them like given a thousand
people did that and I emailed them this
way what was the response rate what if I
emailed in this way what's the response
rate that's automated now that is
prescriptive analytic models
now obviously in the e-commerce sale
there's one side but you're also seeing
the same models used for things like
when should you evacuate a town for a
forest fire
if I wait till it's obvious that the
fire is going to hit the town now I risk
People's Health in the crisis of trying
to get them out or is it better at a low
stress level to say let's move them
early it'll cost us less the chance of
them being injured or killed is lower
and then if the fire goes the other way
it's not that big of a deal right we're
still building prescriptive models to
explore the psychological effects of
emergencies
and being able to act more effectively
to protect people
we can also make video games
so this is one of the open AI models the
the in the early days where you would
describe a game is this someone making a
bad version of asteroids and it would
spit out code for you this is not that
exciting anymore most people have played
hopefully with co-pilot now a whole
other way to pull up code you don't
understand you used to have to use stack
Overflow for this but now you can do a
machine learning model so there's fewer
people saying that's a dumb question
uh
I'm concerned with the training set
we've done a couple of great shows
around this with folks like Michelle
Manning where we you know maybe
generating code that works but isn't
secure
or isn't you know reliable
they've trained it against all of the
open libraries on GitHub and that
doesn't mean that means it's only as
good as the code that we put into GitHub
some of the code I put in the GitHub I'm
not proud of
uh so it is interesting to say how can
they improve this to say hey I only want
highly secure code that's thoughtful of
all of those kinds of things they're now
starting to stick language onto this so
now you're going to talk about what code
you want to write
and the VP of the Power Platform Charles
lamanna announced they've made a version
of copilot for Power Platform
so oh you had a no code solution where
you're draggy dropping the form too much
work just say making me a form
right now use the image recognizer show
them a copy of the paper version of the
foreign it comes up
so those are machine learning models for
programming they're tools for us to use
the whole we will all be replaced by
this is silly it always was silly it's
only getting sillier the longer we use
these things but if you don't use them
in your routine work you're kind of
missing out it's an accelerant there's
no excuse for not understanding the code
you're putting in your system so the
idea that this is an you're already you
were using Google sometimes you're using
stock overflow why wouldn't you use
copilot to pull up code and then
evaluate that code it's easier than a
blank screen it's all anything we can do
to get ourselves moving on a given
problem space
but it's still our discrimination
the tool does not know that this code is
right all it knows it fit the criteria
you describe to it at the time that's as
much to know with some percentage of
probability hopefully in the high 90s
but not always
and chat GPT about the same thing right
there
I call it a dunning-kruger accelerator
if you know nothing about a topic chat
GPT is awesome
as soon as you know something about a
topic and ask chat YouTube It's not that
awesome
not actually concerned with facts
what replaces the smartphone
I mean the smartphone is dominated it's
now the primary compute device but it's
kind of mature you know
the phones get bigger they get smaller
they have one camera two cameras three
cameras way too many cameras
but they're kind of the same they're a
slab of black glass we're kind of right
for disintermediation the obvious device
is some kind of AR headset
right is some pair of glasses that we
can put on that puts the data directory
to our eyes it does everything the phone
does without having to pull it out
all right and actually gives us a bunch
of other capabilities because now we
have instrumentation on our head so that
it can observe the world around us
because we're not paying attention
and that offers a bunch of possibilities
that being said 2023 not a good year for
AR
Apple's just announced this is a mock-up
of what we thought Apple was going to
make it's all a lie and currently Apple
says they're not making anything they've
backed off so whatever prototypes they
were working on internally they're not
happy with them right now there are
commercial products that are glasses
with devices on it this is a Qualcomm
device called the xr1 you can buy this
today it's about a thousand bucks it's
Tethered to an Android phone and it's
just a USB headset that has microphones
and speakers and cameras and and
um and screens integrated into it and
you're seeing these used in certain
commercial applications if you want to
look more like Google Glass you can do
this with the Toshiba devices this is
the Dyna Edge so I want one eye a little
more industrial looking okay this
Hardware exists there is hololens but
hololens is not in a good place if I was
this is the Trimble version of hololens
2 this is the one they wanted to put on
all construction workers because
construction workers are good with
equipment
um at 3 000 bucks a piece plus about a
thousand dollars a month in operating
costs
when I when we started doing some case
studies on implied hololens products I
was stunned at how much Azure eats to
operate it properly like
now for certain markets that makes
perfect sense construction site not so
much
but if you've been paying attention to
the recent round of layoffs you know
they've pretty much laid off the entire
hololens team
the leader of the hololens team a guy
named Alex kittman left Microsoft back
in July so they've been a little bit
leaderless for the past few years then
the Army announced they shut down there
they were going to shut down a project
they want to do more research on it and
then they surrounded layoffs came so it
looks like the hololens is an orphan for
the moment I mean the uh the opportunity
in certain verticals is really
interesting the you know industrial
applications where basically equipment
becomes transparent checklists are live
you're making continuous video record of
the maintenance that you're doing these
are all interesting applied cases I
looked at this very much as the
that the AR glasses were in the same
place that the Blackberry phone was in
like the 1990s
in the 90s if you want an email on your
phone I know crazy
you had to buy these a thousand dollar
phones in the 90s
from from Rim called the Blackberry and
had a little keyboard on it and you had
to run a custom version of Exchange
Server
inside of your organization to make it
work
so you need a couple of guys in lab
coats
and a whole ton of licenses and you too
could have email on your phone and it
was so popular in the 90s they called
them crack berries
but it needed to be the right vertical
it needed that cost had to be worthwhile
that continuous access that person was
important enough right you saw it on
like The West Wing right the politicians
and bureaucrats needed this sort of
thing
and of course today email has been
completely commercialized it's in every
device it's not a big deal but I look at
hololens and the AR devices that way for
the right vertical where you can afford
that expend is Trivial to its value
totally makes sense consumer device no
not there yet
and we don't know when we will be it's
an insanely complex device now the
hololens 2 is six years old we never saw
the hololens 3. so The Tick Tock of
Moore's Law still applying we should be
able to get dramatically better headset
we're just struggling for the
applications for it
I'll make fun of meta very briefly it's
not hard to do anymore it was funnier a
couple of years ago
um
I we would have said hey Zuckerberg
created the largest loss of value in all
time he burned through 10 billion
dollars in a year
but then
I mean Facebook was a trillion dollar
company now it's a 300 billion dollar
company well done
but then you know let's look at Twitter
or Tesla my billionaires messing up
their companies seems to be a style I
presume it will pass
uh these headsets are compelling this
was really John Carmack the guy behind
Oculus that got acquired by Facebook who
is now put down his his lap time and go
okay I've had enough few people and he's
left now too so any sense that
Facebook's along between Cheryl Sandberg
leaving and Andrew and and Carmack
leaving zucks by himself and I think
fairly far off the rails Microsoft
seemed to be playing ball they they
wanted a team's version of this with the
new the quest Pro the 1500 headset in
the Horizon workspace they've now backed
away from this so this is kind of a dark
time in general we're kind of in it for
AR and VR if you are interested in
developing in this space the obvious
tool is Unity like the bulk of
development doing none of the space is
done in unity it's c-sharp Centric it's
his own custom build essentially if
you've never played with this it's an
experience and I recommend the tool
often to kids who think they want to
make games because you can do a few
watch a few videos use a free version of
unity and you can do a lot you can make
a pretty straightforward side scroll and
have an experience and then start to
think more profoundly about the
challenges of writing games
but a lot they what Unity has going for
it is a really good set of 3D libraries
for making it easy to do all of that
three-dimensional work
okay one last topic and then we'll wrap
up Quantum Computing because people love
it so Quantum Computing is a kind of
super Computing it's not likely to be a
regular general purpose compute it's for
super compute problems so the same way
that we build these Titanic
supercomputers for modeling weather and
things these are the kinds of problem
spaces the quantum computers are good
for at there are a number of companies
that are building a variety of different
styles of quantum computers this to me
Likens very much to the late 40s early
50s
in general computing before the
development of the uh of silicon so
every computer is kind of bespoke this
is the Sycamore computer built by Google
it has 54 qubits it was the first to
achieve Quantum Supremacy where it
worked on a particular problem that was
considered thousands of years of compute
in traditional Computing that's
questionable my favorite part of that
story was it's a 54-bit comp quantum
computer except one of the bits was
broken on performance day so it was a 53
qubit run
uh this particular design of quantum
computers uh is what they call transmon
Quantum processing so this is the kind
of this is a way of doing quantum
entanglement with ultra cooled uh
material they cool into liquid helium
uh which is dangerous
the Chinese have a photonic quantum
computer they had up and running in
about 2020 with 100 and 13 entangled
qubits they did a boson sampling compute
in 200 seconds that would have been
multi-billion years of traditional
compute it was a known problem it's kind
of a proof point but again these are
getting there and then IBM's eagle and
Osprey and Condor architectures uh in
the hundred to uh 120 or so qubits that
one was in benchmarking in 28 late 2021
2022 we haven't seen the results from it
yet they were promising by last year to
have a 400 qubit processor that hasn't
materialized yet and this was supposed
to be the year they produced a thousand
qubits that hasn't happened either
but the real question is what the hell
are you going to do with this thing like
the only favorite thing you ever hear in
the news is the end of security that
we're going to be able to break RSA
encryption which is true kinda in the
end encryption strategies that use prime
numbers these very large prime numbers
are susceptible to the compute strengths
of quantum computer if you have four or
five thousand entangled qubits you
should be able to crush through 128
digit primes in a matter of seconds
we don't have to use prime based
encryption there are other kinds of
encryption in fact the NSA is currently
recommending that we switch to lattice
based encryption it's just not as
efficient to encrypt with other kinds of
Christian strategies it turns out the
computers are good at prime numbers it's
a cost-effective ways to do encryption
as well as decryption so forget the
encryption problem solvable not
interesting the most interesting
problems in the quantum Computing space
are actually chemistry problems and the
classic one for me is in agriculture
so in the pre-technological era if you
wanted to grow crops routinely if you
were planting wheat
if you kept growing wheat in the same
chunk of land year over year you got
less and less wheat because you depleted
the soil you had to rejuvenate the soil
now today in an industrial world we have
the Haber Bosch process where we make
industrial fertilizers and after you
have a season of growing wheat you then
fertilize the stod out of that land and
repopulate that replenish the soil to
grow wheat again but before we had that
we rotated crops
and there are bean plants typically that
has a rhizome on it that lives on the
roots and inside of that is an enzyme
called nitrogenase and nitrogenase
naturally affixes nitrogen it takes
water and
nitrogen from the air and in a catalytic
reaction turns it into ammonia so in the
normal crop rotation you would grow a
crop of beans you would harvest the
beans you'd plow the plants under and
then you'd let the land go fallow for a
year you let those roots rot and they
would release fertilizers back into the
soil and then the third year you can
plant wheat again that's the traditional
non-technical way to do it chemical
fertilizers avoided that but chemical
fertilizers have their own cost right
they're about one percent of the energy
consumption of this planet is based on
making Distributing fertilizers so if we
could utilize this thing that a bean
plant could do we could have a
significant impact on agriculture
the problem is that the catalytic
reaction that goes on inside of that
enzyme involves atoms of molybdenum and
iron and it's a 2 to the 170th complex
problem to understand the electron
interaction which is like more atoms
that are on the than they're on the
Earth
a mid-sized quantum computer something
in the 400 Cubit range should be able to
solve this should give us an example of
the correct catalytic reaction that
doesn't mean we'll immediately be able
to implement it but once you know what
the reaction looks like you have a
chance of now engineering an
implementation of it so that we could be
making fertilizer directly from Air
at low power plant power
and be able to grow food more routinely
it's an interesting Quantum problem
there are other quantum chemistry
problems like that battery design is
largely based on experimentation not on
our actual understanding of the
interactions of the compounds what we
have done in battery development today
has gotten really good at iterating on
trying different combinations not
actually understanding the optimal
combination it's a Quantum Computing
problem
modern superconductors the Revco
superonductors which are made from rare
earth materials and bearing cupric oxide
are ceramics that are superconductive at
liquid nitrogen temperatures as opposed
to niobum Tim which is superconducting
it helium temperatures which is way
harder to deal with we've had these
superconductors for about 40 years we
just don't really understand how they
work
and so it's hard to make better ones and
again Quantum Computing quantum
chemistry problem
these are all deterministic problems so
the real question is how many quantum
computers do we need because once you've
solved it you kind of need to solve it
again right it's not a non-determinist
problem where you need to do it every
time like a weather problem it's just a
terministic problem and it reminds me of
of uh
of Thomas Watson's statement when they
were first building mechanical
mainframes for the original version of
IBM where he told this board I think
there's only a market for like five of
these and then they went out selling and
they sold like 25 and it was a
revelation but that was because back
then the computer looked like this
right this is before Intel this is
before the Silicon transistor your
computer looks like this you can't
Envision a smartphone like you can't see
it from there it's it's too hard
the first transistor ever made made in
Bell Labs the geranium transistor looked
like this
it's pretty hard to look at that
and make M1 chip
all right it's a big jump
so going back to that Mainframe
what made traditional Computing useful
was the integrated circuit we suddenly
had a stable reliable way to make bits
we made RAM and then we made processes
for them they were consistent and we
could scale them and Moore's law took
over we got more and more potential
compute I described to three different
kinds of quantum computers today they
were all radically different because
there's not a good qubit yet everybody's
trying to make the right qubit they're
exploring their quantum computers are
very much like these bespoke General
computers from the 40s and 50s
and maybe that's what it's going to take
the my favorite story of this whole
thing is the guy one of the guys who
made this transistor a guy named William
Shockley
he was also the guy who who then created
a company called Fairchild silver
conductor and he tried to make and he
made the first integrated circuits
and when he was trying to figure out the
chem the chemistry was going to needed
to dope it properly and what the ratio
should be and so forth he used an old
style mechanical Mainframe to do the
computation
and that gave him the models to be able
to build the first integrated circuits
that made far more reliable general
purpose computers I wonder if these
flaky goofy unreliable quantum computers
were building today are the compute
devices we'll need to find the reliable
qubit
I don't know the answer to that but I
like how the history Rhymes I do know
this
we're trying to predict the future the
best way to do it is to make it and
that's us we do this we're going to go
out and do some work
these next couple of days we're going to
do a bunch of learning and we're going
to create the future I can't wait to see
what we make thank you for your time
thank you
[Applause]